the number one benefit America offers is
free enterprise its entrepreneurship and
it's for you to be able to do it at
whatever scale any social issue that we
have in America today pick any social
issue that we have in the world today
can and will be solved by entrepreneurs
if we allow to I feel if we encourage
more kids to want to go into
entrepreneurship if we encourage more
universities high school junior high
schools even elementary schools to start
talking about entrepreneurship kids are
gonna come up being inspired to saying
what problem can I sell and if we do
that we're gonna be ok everything is
changing so fast when I tell you
everything the way we're communicating
the way we're doing anything the
highest-paid YouTuber last year was a
seven-year-old that made twenty two
million dollars my favorite product in
the world some people like iPhones some
people like smartphones
some people like food my favorite
product in the world Espino two is the
same mm-hmm so it's so fascinating to
learn about them so if you don't study
what's going on a marketplace you're
gonna be led by somebody else who does
again staying connected to geo-political
paying attention to industries that are
changing and what regulations are
changing allows you to adapt faster and
whoever adapts faster has an edge over
those that adapt slower that we're
trying to stay in the middle as much as
possible because there's a lot that the
left can learn from the right and
there's a lot that the right can learn
from the left I balanced those two out
if I go to someone's home and they say
we never watch Fox News you have blind
spots you're vice you have lion spots
and if I go to someone's house and they
said we never watch CNN now you know
that's fake notes you have blind spots I
intentionally like to sit with people I
disagree with yeah because I want to get
their perspective yes I want to learn
from them it's very easy to only see
what people you agree with that's an
easy conversation but it's sitting with
people that you disagree with their
decision and say how did you get to that
point I think I learn more like that but
yeah people is the most beautiful
product in the world I love it Patrick
sometimes when people that are close of
dying
but they don't die they believe there's
a destiny title
like you're supposed to do something is
this a mathematical formula am i
destined I feel like God's using me in a
way to do something big with my life but
what is it what is the purpose how come
I don't know yet why don't you telling
me so that's the battle
[Music]